Narrator: DIGITAL PROJECTORS.
THEY CREATE DAZZLING IMAGES
WITH INCREDIBLE RESOLUTION.
BUT HOW CAN DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY
PRODUCE ULTRA-HIGH-DEFINITION
MOVING IMAGES
THAT EVEN FILM CAN'T BEAT?
AT THE HEART OF THE PROJECTOR,
A HIGH-PRECISION PRISM
SPLITS WHITE LIGHT
INTO PRIMARY COLORS...
AND THEN BEAMS IT
ONTO THREE MICROCHIPS.
ON THEIR SURFACES,
8.8 MILLION MIRRORS
SMALLER THAN A PINPRICK.
THEY FLICKER
ON MICROSCOPIC HINGES
TO SPLIT UP THE LIGHT BEAM
INTO 8.8 MILLION PIXELS
THAT FORM A MOVING IMAGE.
THE PRISM MERGES THE LIGHT
FROM THE 3 CHIPS
TO PRODUCE 281 TRILLION
SHADES OF COLOR.
THE PROJECTOR CONSUMES
1,600 WATTS OF POWER
AND GENERATES INTENSE AREAS
OF HEAT
THAT COULD RUIN
THE PROJECTOR'S IMAGE.
SO, 105 METAL SPIKES
DRAW HEAT
FROM EACH OF THE CHIPS.
THREE FEET OF METAL TUBING PUMPS
FOUR PINTS OF LIQUID COOLANT
TO CHILL THE BANKS OF LASERS.
AND 19 FANS,
SPINNING 3,000 TIMES A MINUTE,
EXPEL ENOUGH HEAT
TO BOIL A POT OF WATER.
SO, THIS MACHINE CAN SHOW MOVIES
WITHOUT GOING INTO MELTDOWN.
THANKS TO DECADES
OF TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION,
DIGITAL TECHNOLOGY PRODUCES
THE MOST FAULTLESS IMAGES
THAT MOVIE THEATERS
HAVE EVER SEEN.